only on CBS this morning we are hearing
from the Massachusetts Attorney General
who blames the founding family of a
pharmaceutical company for helping
create the opioid drug crisis the CDC
says 400,000 people died from opioid
overdoses between 1999 and 2017 that's
about the equivalent to the population
of Cleveland Ohio in a lawsuit the state
targets Purdue Pharma and eight members
of the Sackler family it alleges they
are personally responsible for
deceptively selling oxycontin Purdue
Pharma calls the accusations a rush to
vilify the drug maker Tony de copal is
at Suffolk County Superior Court in
Boston ahead of a hearing Friday for
this case Tony good morning
hey there good morning I'll tell you one
thing you notice reading through this
lawsuit is that there is a lot that is
still redacted and lawyers for Purdue
Pharma plan to argue tomorrow that it
should stay that way but the Attorney
General of Massachusetts says this is
already the most complete record to date
of how the opioid crisis began and why
members of the Sackler family itself
should be held accountable that be 29 on
Friday and I didn't think I'd make it to
25 to be honest Jonathan Burke says his
battle with addiction began 11 years ago
with a dirt bike accident and a
two-month prescription of oxycontin just
two weeks later he was hooked the way
that your brain becomes reharden
addiction is just absolutely insane
Burke later turned to illegal drugs and
ended up stealing to fund his habit it
literally damaged every relationship
with every family member friend person I
acquired in my life
Burke's home state of Massachusetts is
one of 36 states now suing Purdue Pharma
accusing the company of downplaying the
dangers of oxycontin in a 2007 federal
settlement the company admitted to
falsely selling the drug as less
addictive than rival products the
company paid six hundred and thirty
million dollars in fines but
Massachusetts attorney general Maura
Healey says the dishonesty continued in
her lawsuit she names eight members of
the family that owns Purdue Pharma
alleging they micro managed a deceptive
sales campaign in the conclusion
to the complaint you say that the
Sackler family used the power at their
disposal through Purdue to in your words
engineer and opioid crisis it's pretty
strong words it's pretty reprehensible
conduct Healy alleges Sackler family
members hired hundreds of workers to
carry out their wishes
pushing doctors to get more patients on
opioids at higher doses for longer than
ever before all while paying themselves
billions of dollars they don't want to
accept blame for this they blame doctors
they blame prescribers and worst of all
they blame patients when you say that
you mean Purdue or you mean the Sackler
family or are they one of the same
they're one in the same in one alleged
instance then President Richard Sackler
devised what healy describes as Sackler
solution to the overwhelming evidence of
overdose and death writing in a
confidential email we have to hammer on
the abusers in every way possible
they're the culprits and the problem
this so-called culprit suggests sackler
take a dose of his own medicine I would
personally tell him to take two a day
for two weeks and see how he ends up in
a statement Purdue Pharma calls the
Massachusetts lawsuit a rush to vilify
the drug maker saying it distorts
critical facts and cherry-picked from
among tens of millions of emails and
other business documents if Purdue
thinks were cherry-picking I invite them
to produce all of their documents and
let the public judge for itself so
you're saying they knew that this was
addictive they knew people were dying
and it was greed that drove them forward
of course it was greed now we should
point out we did reach out to the
Sackler family and their lawyer a three
of the settlers declined to comment
through a press representative who
advertises crisis communication and the
rest never got back to us but it's
really no surprise there this is a
family that rarely publicly addresses
it's connection to the company that made
it rich and we'll have much more on that
tomorrow Nora I'm glad we're doing that
a two-part series really interesting
Tony thank you so much great reporting